The national weather service confirmed
that it was an
earthquake that struck nebraska
yesterday this tremor ultimately caused
a malfunction in a weather satellite
government officials say that the
satellite has been fixed and an event
like that reoccurring again is
impossible
oh jordan i told you it was folly
i see you in there
eclipso
can i help you i'm looking for pat dugan
he doesn't live here moved
months ago now any idea where i can find
him
who are you i'm an old friend
named sylvester pemberton
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my star girl finale video
for all the justice society stuff the
season 2 teaser and all the justice
league easter eggs there's a bunch of
stuff so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
we're also getting all the dc movie
trailers at dc fandom in a couple weeks
so it is a really good time to be a dc
fan but as the title of the video
implies careful for spoilers we'll be
talking about everything from the star
girl ending and what's going on with
season two so we'll do top 10 and
easter eggs as we go along because
there's a lot of big characters that
they're setting up
starting with number 10 the new justice
society is able to stop
icicles in justice society from
brainwashing the rest of america
their whole plan was to create a new
america order by making everyone think
and believe the way that they wanted
them to
with them acting is a shadow government
behind the scenes the new wildcat rips
out brainwave's throat killing him
and they blow up their satellite
broadcast tower but number nine shiv
who's one of the injustice society
members betrays her father
killing dragon king or seemingly killing
him we don't know if he's dead jeff
jones wouldn't confirm it
but she winds up living up to her name
and shiving him in the back with her
special abilities so haha see what they
did there
it seems like they're setting her up to
be a much bigger character during season
two as implied by her other end credits
scene
so number eight icicle the team leader
of this version of the team gets
shattered into a million pieces he's
definitely not dead though
but because it seems like the shade is
taking over leadership of the injustice
society in season two he'll probably
just be pretty scarce for the first part
of the season
while he slowly pulls his body back
together the pieces of ice that make up
his body will eventually melt then he
can slowly reconstitute himself
they haven't tried that twist with
killer frost on the flash yet i'm
interested to see if they do that before
they end that show
they yell at grundy to just get the hell
out of there so he just takes off
running they'll go hide in a swamp
somewhere maybe he'll come back during
season two then number seven the shining
knight who we found out was the janitor
this season just takes off at the end
saying he's going to quote unquote find
his horse which is both a metaphor
and a literal thing looking for his
literal horse so he'll probably come
back for a cameo in season two but i
don't expect him to be a really huge
character like he was at the end of
season 1 here
just because they have so many brand new
characters that jeff johns teases
they're introducing
i'll talk about them in a second too
because then everyone's wondering when
the new green lantern is going to show
up and what's going on with dr fate
but number six the shade who's a classic
injustice society team member
but declined their summons in season one
earlier shows up to pick up the pieces
of the shattered team
calling out icicle's plan as being
foolish implying that he has some much
more magically based solution for taking
over the country and getting rid of the
new justice society
they kind of implied earlier this season
when they were having meetings that he
betrayed their team but i think that's
just a reference to him
not coming when they asked him to the
really cool thing about the shades
powers is that he can manipulate
darkness in the dark zone the dark zone
is a primordial darkness
alternate dimension that works a lot
like doctor strange's dark dimension
where dormammu rules
remember how they pulled extra energy
from the dark dimension
it's the same thing with the shade he
can use it to teleport he can create
darkness constructs like green lantern
creates constructs
he can summon shadow demons and control
them and he can create darkness force
fields
in the comics he eventually becomes star
man's ally and turns good so there's
always a chance the tv show
shade could eventually help the justice
society but it seems like for most of
season two at least at the beginning
he'll be driving most of the plot
controlling the new version of the
injustice society
then number five this is probably one of
the biggest moments shiv
releases eclipso from the storage locker
through the heart of darkness
that's what the name of this gem is
eclipso is the being that resides in the
gem the gem itself is called the heart
of darkness
the way she holds the gem up in front of
her eye makes it seem like she might
become one of his first hosts but
part of the fun of eclipso is that he
winds up controlling
everyone so i would be willing to bet
that he winds up taking over
many different heroes and many different
villains during season two
if you're not really familiar with the
character though he is the primordial
manifestation of god's wrath
and was responsible for the great flood
of biblical fame
he's mostly a magic based character but
he has powers of flight
he's immortal he's mostly invulnerable
he has super speed stamina
he has special darkness rays that he
emits that are almost as powerful as
darkseid's omega beams
he also has a mystical darkness sword
and he can use the heart of darkness to
enhance his attacks
the only limitations of the character
are the limitations that the presence
which is the god of the dc universe puts
on him
because he's this big cosmic character
he has to operate by some cosmic rules
the same way that the spectre has to
operate by god's rules
any time they go off the rails the
presence will get involved and sanction
them somehow because the presence is the
most powerful character
in the entire dc universe number four
then they have a bit of a family moment
reconciling
pat is now fully the stripes character
from the comics the giant robot from the
show though is a mech but he'll just
continue helping them during season two
the mom is also a little bit more in on
their secrets it would be weird if they
went for more seasons without her
finding out about the justice society
stuff she'd kind of start to seem like
an idiot
you can only go so long without
characters finding out people's secret
identities
but then number three this is actually a
pretty huge one in north hollywood
back where pat used to live joel
mchale's starman character
shows up at pat's old apartment building
address 912
looking for him claiming he's an old
friend but the big question to ask
though is if it's really him and he
survived this whole time he didn't die
during that first episode flashback
or if it's just someone pretending to be
him because remember we're talking about
comic books they're doppelgangers
all over the place and then you get into
a big crisis on infinite earth's
multiverse story so it's not uncommon to
masquerade as other characters
but it does seem like joel mchale is
gonna star in at least the first couple
of episodes i don't expect him to be in
every single episode but they'll
probably just have fun with the idea of
whether or not the cosmic staff will
return to him or it'll obey courtney
because that's the whole thing is that
it's sentient it does what it wants to
do
number two though jeff johns teased a
bunch of new characters coming in so we
still have alan scott's green lantern
battery it was still glowing the last
time we saw it meaning it was getting
ready to select
a new green lantern i've already done a
couple videos about that
early prediction is that it'll wind up
being jade allen scott's daughter
from the comics but she doesn't actually
need a green lantern ring she's actually
powered by the star heart itself which
is the rock that's inside alan scott's
green lantern battery
but they might change that a little bit
for the tv show either way it just seems
like there'll be more green lantern
legit stuff happening during season two
there's also dr fate which they didn't
really answer any questions about during
season one the helmet of fate is still
in the justice society's headquarters so
it has to select a new where
if the real doctor fate from the past
doesn't show up again there's also
jakeem
and thunder with that pink pen they
haven't answered who's going to get the
pink pen but everybody thinks that it's
going to be jakeem
but number one just in terms of season 2
release date and the move to cw
so if you guys didn't hear the news the
cw effectively took over
the star girl tv show and it's going to
air exclusively on the cw
during season 2 but that's probably not
gonna premiere till the end of next year
but right now it does seem like the dc
universe streaming service is probably
going away
that means titan season 3 will also
probably premiere on hbo max because
it's a little more hardcore
even though it could go either way they
could put it on cw or they could put it
on hbo max
but dc fandom is coming up there's a
couple other big hbo
dc series that they're working on like
the hbo green lantern series
hbo justice league dark so hopefully
they'll give us more details about
what's going on with those series in a
couple weeks
we're also supposed to get a new justice
league snyder cut trailer
a new teaser for the batman movie with
robert pattinson a black adam teaser
shazam 2
and james gunn implied that there would
be some kind of teaser or trailer for
the suicide squad movie that's coming
out next year
everyone click here for that brand new
black suit superman justice league
snyder cut trailer video
and click here for the batman 2021
trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight